qu'est-ce que l'existentialisme c'est en
gros l'idée que l'être humain choisit
son destin choisir son destin c'est
choisir l'environnement dans lequel on
veut évoluer c'est choisir la situation
à laquelle on veut accéder on peut
choisir d'être écrivain on peut choisir
d'être boulanger d'être garçon de café
c'est nous qui décidons c'est nous qui
incarnons notre projet existentiel et
même s'il est évident que chacune de ces
options est plus ou moins difficilement
atteignable selon notre milieu d'origine
selon notre situation sociale ce que
nous dit l'existentialisme c'est que ces
options elles existent n sommes pas
condamnés à être ce que notre
environnement a fait de nous l'important
n'est pas ce qu'on a fait de nous mais
ce qu'on fait de ce qu'on a fait de nous